- Never thought about a career.
Never written a note of music for money.
We're experimenting.
(drums beating rhythmically)
Mighty big, sounds awesome.
Black Hawk Down I remember
being up for 72 hours.
Nobody asked me to be up for 72 hours.
Nobody was throwing anything, you know?
It was fine.
Thank you to the people of
Ghent for not killing me.
There's something very human
about it because it can
only make a sound with air
and it needs to breathe.
- He's a German composer
and record producer.
He's the head of the film
music division at Dreamworks.
He's composed the music for
over 150 films, including
Lion King, Gladiator, and
Pirates of the Caribbean.
He's Hans Zimmer, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number eight is my personal favorite.
Make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Hans is talking,
if he says something
that really, really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(whooshing tone)
(determined music)
(suspenseful music)
- Guy from Germany who stubbornly
just wanted to play music.
- Hans Zimmer is a crazy genius.
- He's just one of the nicest people
I've ever met and a great film composer.
- Never thought about a career.
Never written a note of music for money.
- I don't think a few words to
define Hans the way I know him.
Hans is a genius.
- Somebody who's concerned
with making sure that
we will have orchestras
forever and try to support my
musician friends and try
to discover new people and
never growing up.
- A lot of the producers
go, "Oh my God, no, Hans,
can you not write the thing that you did
so that you get an
Oscar," and this and that.
And he said, "No, I'm going
to do it all differently."
And everybody's scared.
And in the end it's a hit.
And in the end, everybody
copies Hans' music.
- He's this guy that I met 37 years ago
that's written some unbelievable music
and had an incredible career.
- I play music.
That's what I do.
After finishing my
adventures on Dark Knight,
I decided we need to go into
a completely different direction.
(energetic orchestral music)
While I think of the notes for the tune,
I try to think of what's the (mumbles)
pour this tune into, and
that's what we're doing.
Basses, can you make your
accents a bit more fierce?
We're experimenting.
(drums beating rhythmically)
Mighty big.
Sounds awesome.
That's what you're supposed to do.
You're not supposed to stand still.
You don't really want to be observed
at your greatest failures.
You have to invite failure if
you want to go and experiment
and if you want to try
to do something original.
We have to have a certain amount of
privacy to have the courage to fail.
Black Hawk Down or any of
those films we worked on,
nobody asked us to...
Black Hawk Down, I remember
being up for 72 hours.
Nobody asked me to be up for 72 hours.
I was trying to do
something extraordinary.
Trying to tell a story
in an extraordinary way.
Trying to
be a band of brothers.
Not let anybody else down
that was on your team.
- [Interviewer] Be superhuman.
- It's not superhuman.
It's human.
The unfortunate thing is
that you have to put the word
super in front of it
when it's the ambition.
It's what we should all strive for.
That commitment to the
gesture, to the love,
to how we approach the day,
how we approach each other,
how we approach humanity, how we approach
art and beauty and
ultimately, in Martin's case,
how we approach our instrument.
There needs to be respect.
At the end of the day,
I don't think the issue
really is about the recording medium,
but it is about the
players and the whole team.
I think you're not going to
get quite the same results
by having your mate in the
flat next door go and bang
on a biscuit tin, even though
it might be interesting,
than if you get the best
players in the world
to go and know where to hit it.
You know what I mean?
A drum is this interesting archaic thing,
but there are sweet spots
when you hit it just right.
These guys have been doing it forever.
So it's really about the human
beings that go and create
the sound that ultimately will
tell you if it's any good.
The Lion King was, of course, it was huge,
especially because I did it
for all the wrong reasons.
I did it for my daughter because
I wanted to show off as dad.
I was doing all these grown
up movies where people were
getting killed and I couldn't
take her to a premiere.
I wanted to do something to
take my kid to a premiere.
It was surprisingly
emotional doing that movie.
It deals with a father's death, so
it's got a lot more depth than
the surface let me believe.
And it shocked me, my own
response once I started writing
on it because I was thinking
this is going to be easy.
And it wasn't like it was hard,
but the emotional involvement suddenly
became profound as opposed to hard.
And really it was Lion
King that got Terry Malick
interested in me, for instance.
Terry loved Lion King and
wanted me to do Thin Red Line.
Working with Ridley Scott,
we've done some really good
movies together and they're
stylistically so different.
I mean, Black Rain is so
different from Thelma and Louise.
It's so different from Gladiator.
So different from Hannibal.
It's so different from Black Hawk Down.
It's so different from Matchstick Men.
I'm sure I'm leaving some out.
So working with people
who are like me that
get a little bored doing the same thing
and off they go to try to do
something completely different,
that's a big part of it.
When I started, people
were cutting on Steenbecks
and KEMs and then they got the Avid.
The interesting thing
about a sound (mumbles) is
because sound is slightly
more easy to handle
in large quantities of data than images.
We've always been ahead of the image guys.
I mean of the film guys.
So we've made all those
mistakes with digital.
The old digital recordings sound bad
and it wasn't just the technology.
We didn't know how to use it.
Part of that is just you
have to put your hours in.
I'm a real believer in that thing,
it's 10,000 hours to
get good at something.
- [Interviewer] Is that the big difference
because I see you in your basement like
a Batman with all machines and stuff.
It's really precise, I guess.
You know what you put
and then you go live.
What's the difference?
The risk?
- Energy.
The risk.
I have stage fright and I
never confronted the risk.
I mean, Belgium.
Year 2000.
You have no idea what it
took then to get me to do it.
No, no, no, no, I had 1,000
excuses why not to do it,
and then finally I did it and it was
exquisitely horrifying.
That's the only way I can put it.
- [Interviewer] Complex.
- Yes, it was very,
very, very, very complex.
What was really good was
right at the beginning
within two seconds, I played
just the worst wrong note.
I could either stop and cry
or I could laugh, right?
And it didn't kill me,
and nobody else out there.
Nobody was throwing anything.
It was fine.
Thank you to the people of
Ghent for not killing me
and giving me the courage,
and the absurdity.
You have to be able to laugh at yourself
and you have to learn
how to laugh at yourself.
The greatest compliment
I think I've ever gotten,
better than an Oscar, better
than a Grammy, et cetera,
was towards the end of the
last Dark Knight Rises.
Working with those percussionists
that we've just sampled,
these guys have played on everything.
They are the guys.
There's nothing they haven't played.
So my great ambition has
always been to go and do just
one thing where they go,
wow, never done that before.
I actually figured something.
I'm not going to go into the details,
but number one, I got
the compliment of going,
"Wow, we've never done this before
"and it sounds really good."
I was terrible at school.
I never managed to go to university.
But I started working for
another film composer.
What happened literally on
day one, I am in the room.
My job is to make coffee.
But I'm in a room with
Nick Roeg, who I adore
as a director, and Stanley
Myers, who I adored
as a composer, and they're
talking about the scene.
There's a real live problem.
How are we going to score
the scene as opposed to
what I experienced in
school, which is somebody
tells you some historical
incident that then got solved.
So the most important part of
the mentorship was not only
was I in the room with a
problem that had not been solved
and I was witnessing how this
problem in front of my eyes
got solved by Stanley going,
"Oh, what about those notes,"
and Nick going, "That's exactly it,"
but just being in a room with people
who were the best at what the did.
In a funny way I thought everybody
should have the right to this.
So I try to make this place...
This is a big room.
When it's not full of Dark Knight synth,
there's actually a lot of room in here.
I think something really
good happens if you can be.
You know, it's your first day.
You're here to make coffee, but you're in
the room with Chris Nolan and Hans Zimmer
and you're seeing them
scratching their head.
Somehow, even if you
don't open your mouth,
just by your presence,
you're part of the solution,
or at least you get to see it.
This is, of course,
where Chris gets tricky.
Really about a father and
his relationship to his son.
It's only later on that I found out
that the son wasn't the son at all.
It was a daughter.
(solemn music)
I sat down and I wrote this
piece really about what it feels
like to be a father and what
it feels like to have a son.
I was writing about my son.
- When he played me the piece of music,
which became the basis
for the entire score,
I thought it was absolutely
perfect and captured
the emotional qualities
of the film that I wanted.
It was at that point that
I told him that it was
actually a large scale
science fiction film.
I hadn't given him any clues about that.
You know, it's not an action film.
It's not about (background
music drowns out speaker).
I think what that did for
him is it set him very firmly
in a direction related
to the heart of the film.
I listened to it extensively
while I was finishing writing
the script and then when we
were in production as well.
- The organ really is a huge,
complicated synthesizer.
If you think about it, you
have a pipe and air blows
through it and that makes a sound,
and it makes the sound of one pitch.
And then if you want to shift color,
you add another pipe to
it and you add more pipes.
And so it becomes these really very,
very complex harmonic structures.
There was this endless discovery
going on for both Chris and me where
Roger would take us through
all these different voicings
and all these different colors.
You can even go a little darker.
Actually, then we should
go for this sound.
There's something very human
about it because it can
only make a sound with air
and it needs to breathe.
On each note, you hear the breath.
You hear the exhale.
- You feel a human presence in
every sound and I think that
was very important to keeping
the film about not just the
space that we're looking at,
but the people in that space.
There's an intimacy as
well as massive scale.
Sometimes within a few
bars, there's that shift.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Pulling out all the stops.
I now know what that
expression means for real.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
David Dumais asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which rule
had the biggest impact on you.
What did Hans say that is
going to have an impact
on your life or business somehow?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join into the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout out to Fred McCormack.
Fred, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(whooshing tone)
- I think the only thing
that can save us at the end
of the day as a human race is science.
The only thing that inspires science
all the time is dreamers.
Would we have gotten to the moon without
(mumbles) or Isaac Asimov.
I don't know good design that's...
- [Interviewer] So you're hopeful
because we still have art?
Heart and art?
- I think I'm hopeful.
I'm hopeful because I'm a musician.
I'm realizing this more
and more what happens is
it's not that we can play really well.
We learn how to listen.
We learn how to listen to each other.
So we can come from
totally different cultures.
We might not be able to speak
the same words as language.
But when we all get
together, if I got a bunch
of musicians into this room
right now, we'd start playing.
The first thing we would do is
we would listen to each other.
There comes respect and empathy.
The only way that music can get beautiful
is if we listen to each other.
I think it's something some politicians
can learn a little something from.
All politicians should be
forced to learn an instrument
and have to jam together every weekend.
- [Interviewer] And listen to each other.
- And listen to each other
because you got to shut up.
You can't be right.
It's indefensible music.
It's not about being right or wrong.
There are no right notes,
they're no wrong notes.
But it's like, I throw you a note,
what are you going to do with it?
I'm not trying to be pretentious about it,
but the listening part is quite good.
It's not unimportant.
Sampling isn't the reason
that concert halls are empty.
What our job is is to drive music forward,
to make it interesting, to
make it commercial in the best
possible sense, to say an
orchestra can rock out.
You can go and see an
orchestral performance
and it'll knock your socks off.
I'm just interested in seeing
how far we can push that.
Movies is one way,
sampling is another way.
Life performance is another way.
It's one of the reasons
I love working with
(mumbles) because he does
these shows in front of
250,000 people and they go nuts.
It's just one man and his synthesizers.
He's just written his first symphony
which was performed in Amsterdam.
Yes, with a full orchestra.
So these ideas are not mutually exclusive.
Tools are tools.
All music relies on technology.
A violin is just a bit of good
carpentry and some dead cats.
It does involve a certain amount
of technology to get you there.
At the end of the day, it's
the ingenuity of the player
and it's the ingenuity of
the composer that are going
to go and really make
something out of this thing.
Somebody said to me
recently, "When you don't
"feel the nerves, you have
to go and do something else."
I feel the nerves, trust me.
(uplifting orchestral music)